si l'on en croit les astrophysiciens
notre univers serait composé à plus de
80% d'une matière inconnue qu'on n'a
jamais directement observer et dont la
nature et les propriétés nous échappe
complètement
la matière noire mais si on l'a jamais
observée ni détecter cette matière noire
comment on fait pour être sûr qu'elle
existe
[Musique]
les premiers indices concernant la
matière noire ont déjà plus de 80 ans en
1933 un astronome suisse fritz vie qui
observent ce qu'on appelle la mas de
coma qui est un groupe de galaxies
situées à plus de 300 millions d'années
lumière de nous et celui qui constate
que les galaxies s'y déplacent comme si
l'ama contenait beaucoup plus de matière
que ce qu'on était capable d'estimer en
l'observant ziki suggère alors qu'il y
aurait dans l'âme à une grande quantité
de matières qu'il qualifie de sombres
qui ne mettraient pas lumière et qui
expliquerait ce mouvement anormal des
galaxies alors à première vue il n'y a
pas de quoi s'étonner qu'ils aient de la
matière qui n'émettent pas de lumière
après tout il y en a plein autour de
nous un les planètes les astéroïdes les
lune etc
oui sauf que tout ça ça pèse rien en
comparaison des étoiles par exemple
jupiter la plus grosse planète du
système solaire ne pèse qu'un millième
de la masse du soleil donc pour
expliquer la matière noire
il faut trouver une autre explication
que les planètes mais avant d'aller plus
loin il faut qu'on comprenne mieux en
quoi étudier le mouvement de corps comme
des galaxies ou des étoiles permet de
faire des estimations de masse pour ça
on va prendre l'exemple du système
solaire je vous ai mis ici les huit
planètes que vous connaissez bien et
plutôt en bonus avec leurs vitesses
moyennes respectives pour marquer un
truc plus les planètes sont éloignés du
soleil plus leur vitesse est faible en
fait tout ça est parfaitement logique et
ça se calcule très bien grâce à la loi
de la gravitation universelle de newton
on peut directement relié la vitesse
d'une planète à sa distance au soleil
alors pour les férus de détails on écrit
simplement que la force centrifuge est
égale à la force de gravité et on sort
que la vitesse est inversement
proportionnelle à la racine carré de la
distance et cette formule colle
parfaitement à ce qu'on observe mais
surtout on voit qu'elle fait apparaître
la masse du soleil ce qui veut dire
qu'en connaissant la vitesse et la
distance des planètes
on peut déduire la masse du soleil ziki
en faisant un calcul de ce genre mais
adapté à l'échelle d'un amas de galaxies
trouve pour la mode comme à une masse
totalement incompatible avec la quantité
des toiles qu'on pouvait observer et
c'est comme ça que de vie qui déduit
qu'il manque de la masse et qu'elle doit
provenir d'une hypothétique matière
noire
toute cette histoire de masse manquante
et de matière noire est resté une
curiosité pendant quelques décennies
mais à la fin des années 70 une
astronome américaine verra roubine
enfonce définitivement le clou en
utilisant des télescopes évidemment plus
puissants que ceux de devis qui verra
roubine réalise des observations
directement au sein des galaxies
il faut savoir qu'une galaxie a
généralement la forme d'un disque aplati
éventuellement en spirale et que toutes
les étoiles tournent autour du centre un
peu comme les planètes autour du soleil
et comme pour le système solaire on
s'attend donc à ce que les étoiles de la
périphérie se déplacent moins vite que
celle du centre verra robin traces pour
plusieurs galaxies ce qu'on appelle leur
courbe de rotation c'est à dire un
graphique qui montre la vitesse des
étoiles en fonction de leurs distances
au centre de la galaxie et elle observe
que toutes ses courbes se comporte de la
même manière et notamment que la vitesse
des étoiles finit par stagner au fur à
mesure qu'on s'éloigne du centre au lieu
de diminuer comme on aurait pu s'y
attendre ces observations remarquable
apporte la preuve indiscutable qu'au
sein même des galaxies on a un problème
de masse manquante et on commence alors
sérieusement à parler de matière noire
alors petite remarque en passant à ces
observations qui sont déterminants pour
la physique moderne date d'il ya plus de
40 ans et on n'a toujours pas jugé bon
de filet le prix nobel avait rares ou
bine enfin ça c'est ce que j'avais mis
dans mon script que j'ai écrit
mi-décembre mais malheureusement verra
robin est décédé le 25 décembre 2016
sans avoir le nobel donc alors depuis
les travaux de verre à robin on a
beaucoup reproduit et affiner les
mesures des courbes de rotation et on
est même capable de le faire pour notre
propre galaxie la voie lactée
ces cours nous permettent de savoir
d'une part que la masse des galaxies
seraient composés aux quatre cinquièmes
de matière noire et en plus elle nous
permet d'estimer la manière dont cette
matière noire et répartis dans les
galaxies la forme des courbes de
rotation nous apprend qu'en plus de la
matière classique les étoiles le gaz qui
se répartissent généralement en un
disque aplati existerait un immense
allostériques de matière noire qui
s'étendrait même au delà de la zone de
la matière lumineuse
ok mais si elle est là cette matière
noire elle est faite de quoi
l'hypothèse qui paraît la plus naturelle
pour expliquer la présence de la matière
noire
c'est d'imaginer qu'il s'agirait
d'astres qu'il n'émettrait pas de
lumière mais qui serait suffisamment
dense pour apporter beaucoup de masse
sans qu'on les voit trop on peut penser
notamment à des trous noirs à des naines
brunes qui sont des étoiles qui n'ont
pas vraiment réussi à s'allumer ou
encore à des étoiles à neutrons qui sont
des cadavres des toiles et dont la
densité peut être cent mille milliards
de fois celle des planètes ou des
étoiles classique
tous ces objets on les regroupe sous
l'acronyme des matchs chose ça veut dire
massive compact à l'eau object si cette
hypothèse est la bonne cette matière
noire n'aurait rien de fondamentalement
mystérieux parce qu'elle serait composé
des particules classiques dont on a
l'habitude des atomes des protons et
neutrons
on regroupe sous le terme générique de
barrio donc dans ce cas là on parlerait
de matière noire baryonique cette
hypothèse peut paraître séduisante mais
dans les années 80 un physicien
israélien mordehaï milgrom propose une
explication assez différente au problème
de la masse manquante
il se dit que si la courbe de rotation
des galaxies n'est pas ce qu'elle
devrait être
c'est pas forcément parce qu'il ya de la
matière mystérieuse qu'on n'a pas réussi
à observer mais peut-être tout
simplement parce que les lois de la
gravité sont différentes de ce qu'on
s'imagine il ya un précédent assez
amusant à ce débat dans le système
solaire lui même au 19e siècle on avait
remarqué que la planète uranus ne se
déplaçait pas comme le prévoyaient les
lois de newton
certains étaient convaincus que c'était
à cause de la présence d'une autre
planète qu'on n'arrivait pas encore
avoir
et grâce à ses calculs l'astronome
français urbain le verrier a pu prouver
la présence et calculer la position de
cette planète mystérieuse qui a ensuite
été observé directement et qu'on appelle
neptune on avait un problème dans une
trajectoire et la réponse était un corps
massif qu'on n'avait pas encore vu
inversement au début du xxème siècle ont
cherché à expliquer certaines anomalies
de l'orbité de mercure et grâce aux
travaux d'einstein ont compris que ce
n'était pas un problème de masse
manquante ou de planète qu'on n'aurait
pas encore découvertes mais que c'était
parce que les lois de la gravité était
différente de celle de newton
quand les champs gravitationnels
deviennent très intense c'est la théorie
de la relativité générale
on avait un problème de trajectoire mais
cette fois il fallait changer les lois
de la gravité
et du coup en 1983 mille grammes se dit
que c'est peut-être la même chose
peut-être qu'il n'y a pas du tout de
matière noire à découvrir mais
simplement les lois de la gravité sont
différentes de celle de newton
mais cette fois contrairement à la
relativité générale quand le champ
gravitationnel devient
très très faible il faut bien voir que
pour une étoile située en périphérie
d'une galaxie le champ gravitationnel
exercée par la masse du reste de la
galaxie est très faible du genre un
milliard de fois plus faible que ce que
nous on a à la surface de la terre et on
n'a jamais pu tester par des expériences
les lois de la gravité dans des champs
aussi faible donc on pourrait
effectivement imaginer qu'elle soit
différente de la loi de newton milgrom
propose en particulier la modification
suivante en dessous d'un certain seuil
la force de gravité ne diminueraient
plus comme le carré de la distance en 1
/ r carré mais en 1 / r on appelle ça la
théorie monde c'est pour modify newton
janda les knicks une des beautés de la
théorie monde sait qu'elle colle
parfaitement avec l'idée de courbes de
rotation des galaxies qui deviennent
plate parce que si l'accélération
gravitationnelle finit par diminuer en 1
/ r il est normal que la vitesse de
rotation de vienne constante quand on
s'éloigne suffisamment séduisant non
avec la théorie monde plus aucun
problème de masse manquante ou de
matière noire
oui sauf qu'il ya quand même plusieurs
trucs qui clochent le premier c'est que
dans certaines régions on observe une
répartition qui est clairement
différente pour la matière ordinaire et
pour la matière noire
c'est par exemple ce qu'il ya dans ce
qu'on appelle la mas du boulet il s'agit
d'un amas de galaxies qui est le
résultat de la collision de deux amas
précédent et pour lequel les
observations montrent une répartition
bien différente pour la matière noire et
la matière lumineuse
ce qui ne colle pas du tout avec la
théorie monde très récemment en août
2016 on a même observé une galaxie
dragonfly 44 qui serait composé à plus
de 99 % de matière noire
ce qui là aussi colle pas vraiment avec
l'idée de la théorie monde d'une simple
modification des lois de la gravité mais
on a d'autres indices qui pointent vers
une nature encore plus étrange pour la
matière noire et qui nous viennent de la
manière dont l'univers s'est formé
le big bang a eu lieu il y à 13,8
milliards d'années est la meilleure
preuve que l'on est de cette période
très dense et très chaude de l'histoire
de l'univers c'est ce qu'on appelle le
rayonnement cosmologique aussi appelé
rayonnement fossile
une des particularités de ce rayonnement
c'est que quelle que soit la direction
dans laquelle on regarde il est
exactement le même
enfin pas tout à fait exactement ils
fluctuent très légèrement d'une
direction à l'autre un jour je vous
ferai une vidéo spécifique sur le thème
des fluctuations du rayonnement
cosmologique
mais ce qu'il faut savoir pour l'instant
c'est qu'en analysant ces fluctuations
on peut tracer une courbe le spectre de
puissance des fluctuations angulaire
dont la forme nous apporte une foule de
détails sur la composition de l'univers
la position du premier pic que vous
voyez ici nous renseigne sur la quantité
totale de matière présente dans
l'univers et donc sur la courbure de
l'univers tandis que la taille des pics
suivant permet spécifiquement de
distinguer la matière ordinaire de celle
qui n'interagissent pas avec le
rayonnement électromagnétique
si la matière noire était de la matière
normale baryonique comme des atomes des
protons ou des neutrons le premier pic
serait plus haut et les pics suivant
plus bas le fait que la taille des pics
soit celle ci trahit la présence de
matière noire non baryonique et permet
même d'en estimer la proportion environ
80%
cette observation est vraiment très
importante parce qu'elle nous montre que
la matière noire ne peut pas être
simplement de la matière ordinaire qui
se serait retrouvée condensé dans des
trous noirs ou des étoiles à neutrons
il s'agit d'un team de matières qui
n'interagit pas avec les ondes
électromagnétiques quelque chose de
vraiment différent
ces conclusions on les retrouve aussi
dans les scénarios qui simule la manière
dont les hétérogénéités initiale de
l'univers au moment du big bang ont fini
par donner naissance aux amas de
galaxies
en bref ces observations cosmologie qui
disqualifie la théorie monde mais aussi
les machos les objets compact baryonique
il faut chercher autre chose de vraiment
plus exotique la piste qui est
privilégié à l'heure actuelle pour
expliquer cette matière noire c'est
celle des winx les weekly interactive
massif particles des particules massives
interagissant faiblement alors alerte
jeu de mots un winch en anglais ça veut
dire mauviettes
c'est pour contraster avec les machos
mais ça pourrait être quoi ces
particules mystérieuse et ben rien de ce
qu'on connaît déjà
on a pensé un temps où neutrinos on sait
aujourd'hui qu'ils ont une masse mais
celle ci est bien trop faible pour
expliquer toute la matière noire
beaucoup ont pensé à des particules
dites super symétriques alors la
supersymétrie c'est une théorie qui une
extension de la physique des particules
classique et qui prévoit tout un tas de
nouvelles particules la supersymétrie
assez populaire parce qu'elle est
notamment indispensable à la théorie des
cordes dans le problème c'est qu'au lhc
on n'a jamais pu observer la moindre
particules supersymétriques et il ya
beaucoup de personnes qui commencent à
sérieusement douter leur existence
autres théories alternatives des
particules qu'on appelle les actions ce
sont des particules qu'on n'a jamais
détectés mais qui pourrait expliquer
certaine symétrie un peu inattendu de la
force nucléaire forte aujourd'hui il
existe un certain nombre d'expériences
en cours ou planifiés pour détecter ces
différents candidats de particules wink
que ce soit soit en les détectant
directement soit en détectant le produit
de leur annihilation
mais bon à ce jour on n'a eu aucun
résultat et si la matière noire n'était
qu'une impasse si finalement la proche
monde était la bonne pas forcément dans
sa forme actuelle mais du moins dans
l'idée d'essayer de modifier les lois de
la gravité
plutôt que de chercher une hypothétique
matière noire qui n'arrête pas de se
dérober à nous ce débat a été récemment
relancé par deux publications
la première en août 2016 qui a montré
une nouvelle fois sur un groupe de 153
galaxie une extraordinaire similarités
dans la forme des courbes de rotation
exactement comme le prévoir est la
théorie monde
la seconde publication on la doit à eric
verlinden un physicien théoricien
néerlandais qui est assez célèbre pour
ses travaux en théorie des cordes depuis
quelques années vers linde et travaille
à une approche radicalement différente
du problème de la gravité dans laquelle
il considère que la gravité est une
force d'origine anthropique
alors je vais pas vous décrire en détail
son approche j'avais écrit un billet de
blog sur le sujet il ya quelques années
donc pour ceux que ça intéresse je
mettrai le lien dans la description
toujours est il que récemment vers linde
et a suggéré que son approche permettait
de retrouver les équations de la théorie
monde tout en résolvant certains
problèmes
alors il faut être prudent 1 pour
beaucoup de physiciens ses idées sont
encore au stade très très flou et il
semble que le buzz autour de cette
publication a été largement exagéré mais
ce qui est intéressant dans son idée
c'est d'essayer de trouver une vraie
justification théorique fondamentale aux
équations de la théorie monde qui
aujourd'hui sont juste des équations
haddock qu'ont été bricolé pour coller
aux courbes de rotation comme vous voyez
la question la matière noire a encore de
quoi pas mal occupé les physiciens dans
les prochaines années
que ce soit sur le plan de la théorie
des expériences ou bien des observations
astrophysiques
avant de conclure je voudrais quand même
dire un tout petit mot sur l'énergie
noire j'ai fait exprès de ne pas en
parler mais si vous connaissez la
matière noire vous avez déjà
certainement entendu parler qu'en fait
notre univers contiendrait en plus une
immense quantité d'énergie noire qui
fait que la composition de l'univers
serait plutôt 70% d'énergie noire 25 %
de matière noire et 5 % de matière
ordinaire
bref que 95% de la nature de l'univers
nous serait inconnu ouais mais non
j'aime pas trop cette manière de
présenter les choses qui laissent
exagérément penser que l'énergie noire
serait une espèce de substance qu'il
faudrait détecter ou découvrir alors
qu'en fait non à l'énergie noire et la
matière noire c'est pas du tout la même
chose
l'énergie noire c'est avant tout un
problème de théorie et ça se trouve
c'est même pas un problème du tout pour
ceux que ça intéresse j'ai écrit un
billet sur le sujet et je vous mettrai
le lien dans la description
merci d'avoir suivi la vidéo si elle
vous a plu n'hésitez pas à vous abonner
si vous êtes déjà abonné n'hésitez pas à
cliquer sur la cloche qui paraît
maintenant il faut dire que son cliquez
sur la cloche qui ont cliqué sur la
cloche
vous pourrez suivre les actus la chaîne
sur facebook et sur twitter et ceux qui
tuent elles peuvent se soutenir sur type
merci à bientôt
[Musique]